Sei unser Winkelkreis.
Das festigt meinen Entschluss, doch was mit Holz zu machen.
Ich hab noch was vergessen. So, hallo und herzlich Willkommen zur Freak Show Nummer 239, wenn ich in meiner Zeitrechnung einen Glauben checken darf.
Mit den Freak-Stars. Freak Show All-Stars.
Mit den Freak Show All-Stars. Wir haben alle Stars für euch zusammengesammelt. Hier live auf dem Chaos Communication Camp 2019 in Mildenberg.
Wie man hören kann.
Wir haben sogar Tellerkopf-Schrauben.
Mit jetzt neu.
Ihr könnt uns gar nicht.
Rostfreier Stahl, nicht diese verzinkte Scheiße, mit der du da angekommen bist.
Ich hab auch Tellerkopf-Schraube. Ich bin Tims Hinweis gefolgt. Und rostet nicht.
Meine rostet auch nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, was du willst. Meine sind nur verzinkt.
Wie, du hast nicht das unten rechts Modell?
Schon haben wir den Sendungstitel.
Nur verzinkt.
Ich bin immer für einen Upgrade zu haben. Na gut, bevor wir zu den Details des Glampings kommen, möchte ich euch erstmal herzlich begrüßen, weil wir haben alles zusammengekratzt, was die Freak Show in den letzten Jahren hervorgebracht hat.
Nein.
Lass doch mal den Tim erst uns alle vorstellen.
Das war mein Ziel, Clemens. Mit mir?
Also Timme, wie immer.
Ja, genau, Timme, wie immer.
Clemens zu meiner Rechten.
Dennis auch, wie immer. Ein Original, Dennis.
Ja, du darfst weitermachen.
Clemens hat aus.
Eine Letty.
Clemens hat Zeit. Ja, das ist ja auch toll, dass du Zeit hast.
Sein Sofa ist am Stromdagen bestimmt.
Also Letty ist da. Was ist mit dem Zwischenapplaus? Roddy das geflügelte Einhorn.
Roddy von Unicornia.
Genau, Unicornia. Village of Unicornia.
Das mit den Einhornen, das hat ja auch so eine gewisse, soll ich sagen, Verdichtung erfahren auf diesem Camp.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist auch gut so.
Ja, das ist auch gut so. Da müssen wir auch gleich drüber sprechen. Weiter geht's mit Hucke.
Huckelihucke.
So läuft das hier.
Dann haben wir noch Tala. Die Datentaler.
Die Datentaler.
Und Michi ist auch dabei.
Alles für euch.
Alle acht Ports ausgereizt.
Aber Tim, da fehlt noch jemand.
Was? Ja, wir müssen natürlich Rainer noch erwähnen. Wo ist denn Rainer?
Auch Rainer. Der ist da links.
Guck mal, da hinten winkt einer im Dunkeln.
Okay, mach das nochmal bitte, Rainer. So, ja, das ist mehr.
Ganz, ganz scheues Reh, aber hat in den letzten, ich weiß nicht wie viel, 350.000 Folgen bereits Intros geliefert, Previouslys geliefert für die Freak Show. Und wir haben sogar den Flo gleich auch noch daneben, den kannst du auch gleich nochmal anleuchten.
Guck mal da, jetzt anleuchten, da.
Das ist nämlich der Typ, der dieses geniale Freak Show Intro verbockt hat.
Und Tim, um dir jetzt mal direkt ins Wort zu fallen, wir haben noch jemanden für dich. Eine neunte Person, die mal bitte auf die Bühne kommen möchte.
Eine neunte Person?
Ich weiß von nichts.
Das lang verschollene neunte Freak Show Mitglied.
Genau, also mehr Freak Show geht nicht.
Ja, das ist jetzt noch ein Freak Show Max.
Wollt ihr in den Freak Show Park?
Ja, ja, rutsch mal hier noch.
Also ein bisschen Headsets.
Auf das die Bierbank bricht.
Na ja, Tim, du hast zu mir gesagt, du kannst auch 12 Ports. Und ich bin fest davon ausgegangen, dass du... oder 12 Kanäle.
Was? Hab ich nicht gesagt.
Doch, hast du zu mir gesagt. Was? Und nicht so zu nehmen, ey, das läuft.
Ich war betrunken, das war... Ich war beeindruckt von dir, ich wollte angeben.
Da war Joe besser, der meinte, wir können bis zu 32 Kanäle alles. Und du hast nur 8.
Versagt.
Fehlkauf. 8 Ports.
Ja, ich bin die 8-Bit-Ausgabe des Podcasts. Wie auch immer. Was kommt jetzt noch mehr?
War Max eigentlich, warst du letztes Mal da? War das noch Mobile Max?
Ich glaube, das war schon Freak Show.
Nein, wir haben genau nach dir umgeschaltet.
Ach, ernsthaft?
Nee, ich war doch noch mal 20, 14 da oder so was.
Zu Besuch.
Zu Besuch, genau.
Einmal mit Profis.
Gut, läuft. Haben wir noch Tim? Okay, also wir sind, muss man ja auch vielleicht mal den Leuten, die nicht gerade hier rum sitzen, auch noch mal kurz erklären. Wir sitzen hier im Three Headed Monkey, was eine großartige Bühne hat, was noch etwas mehr ist als nur eine Bühne. Es ist hier so ein Space auf dem Camp, wo halt hier auch auf dieser Bühne Vorträge, Podcasts, alles Mögliche. Auch stattfinden und auch schon stattgefunden haben. Ja, jetzt sind wir auch noch dabei und müssen jetzt eigentlich mal langsam in die Sendungsplanung vorankommen, dachte ich mir so. Aber vielleicht können wir ja damit anfangen, dass ihr mal so...
Haben wir einen Chat?
Was?
Haben wir einen Chat? Ob wir einen Chat haben?
Wir hören nicht irgendwie nicht. Kriegen wir dich auch auf unserem Kopfhörer?
Ja, das ist das Problem. Wir haben vielleicht einen Chat, soll ich den jetzt auch noch mitlesen?
Was muss ich denn noch eigentlich alles tun?
Protokoll schreiben.
Also wir haben bestimmt irgendwo einen Chat. So, ja dann Letty, erzähl doch mal. Ich kann ja nicht alles machen.
Wo soll ich denn anfangen?
Na ja, keine Ahnung.
Wie war so das Camp für dich bisher?
Hell dunkel, hell dunkel und sehr viel See in der Tat.
Ach, du bist nur geschwommen oder was?
Ja, ich dachte mir, zweimal am Tag nicht nur duschen, sondern auch in den See springen.
Hast du dann auch Algen mitgebracht?
Ich gehe da nicht in dieses Kinderding rein. Ach so. Ich fahre außerhalb.
Möchte gerne den großen See haben. Ja, okay, gut, das verstehe ich.
Also ich hab keine Algen gesehen. Ich hab einmal den Fehler gemacht, ich bin in den See euphorisch reingesprungen, der so ein bisschen fischig riech. Das hab ich direkt bereut.
Ich fand den See jetzt hier gar nicht so schlecht. Ja, am Anfang, mittlerweile sind die Algen weg.
Ja, die storben alle schon. Die Algen sterben zuerst.
Die Algen sterben? Wieso vom Hackergift oder was? Ja, ich hab ja die These, die These...
Besser.
Jetzt sehen wir auch das Publikum.
Seht ihr uns noch?
Ich hab ja die These... Okay, dann wenn ihr uns noch seht, ist gut.
Aber die Kamera nicht mehr.
Ich hab mir die These aufgestellt, dass, jetzt weiß ich ja bis vergessen, welche These ich aufgestellt habe, verdammte Axt. Ich hab die These aufgestellt, dass die Leute die Algen rausbringen.
Na, aus dem See.
Dann, wenn ich das erste Mal reingeschwommen bin, waren da überall Algen. Als ich heute rausgeschwimmen bin, waren da fast gar keine Algen mehr.
Ich hab die vorhin so am Ufer liegen sehen.
Genau.
Also quasi, was früher Bällebad sortieren waren, ist jetzt Algenentfernung, professionelle Algenentfernung aus dem See. Das finde ich ganz hervorragend. Das ist schon ein ganz toller Aspekt dieses Camps.
Vielleicht liegt es auch an der Grandawasser-Informierung, die vorgenommen wurde.
Ach so, stimmt, da war ja ein Schild.
Der See wurde informiert.
Und seitdem wissen die Algen Bescheid, dass sie da nicht sein dürfen und haben sich verzogen.
Und direkt ein Biotop und haben sich entwickelt.
Kommen wir zu dem Segment, mein schönstes Erlebnis auf dem Camp.
Wer möchte anfangen?
Jetzt schon?
Wann denn sonst?
Ist doch noch Camp.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist doch noch Camp. Das hört sich an, als wär's schon vorbei.
Ja, aber wir können ja nur bis hier hin.
Ich hab zwei. Das erste, ich hab gezweifelt an deine Tellerkopfschrauben-Geschichte.
Wirklich?
Und dann zwei Tage vor der Losfahrt, dachte ich mir, fuck it, ich probier's mal aus. Ich hab von Eisenron zehn Tellerkopfschrauben bestellt. Ich glaube, die sind auch rostfrei, wer weiß. Ich muss noch mal gucken. Makita-Bohrschrauber auch eingepackt. Und ich muss sagen, es war geil.
Vor allem hier, wo sozusagen unter zwei Zentimeter Rasenschicht so dieser Industrie-Schotter lagert.
Leute, ich kann euch das wirklich nur sagen. Alle anderen mit ihren Heringen, das sieht nicht gut aus. Mit diesen Tellerkopfschrauben, die gehen auch bis zum Boden runter, die sitzen bombenfest. Und wir waren am Anfang nicht sicher, ob wir da, wo wir sein wollten, sein durften. Und ich dachte mir, mit den Schrauben, das Zelt bewegt keiner. Erstens müssen die das richtige Bitt finden. Also das war ein voller Erfolg. Da hab ich lange stolz von erzählt. Und dann vorhin geh ich an die Bar und bestell mir ein Wasser. Und diese Posten-Nerds, die habt ihr bestimmt auch schon gesehen, die Chaos-Post, die hier wie wild umher rennen, die standen da so und sahen auch ein bisschen dehydriert und sonnengebrannt aus. Und irgendwie, wir quatschten da auch noch, dann irgendwann bestell ich mein Wasser. Und dann sprang die mich ganz freudestrahlend an, denn sie hatten eine Postkarte für mich, auf der der Adressat ist an eine Person, an der Three Headed Monkey Bar, die ein koffeinfreies, nicht alkoholisches Getränk bestellt. Sie sahen so aus, als hätten sie da lange gestanden, weil alle nur Marte oder Bier bestellen. Und ja, das war, leider war dann der Rest dieses Briefes oder diese Postkarte nicht so aufregend, aber es war schön. Auf der Postkarte steht, der liebe Gott sieht alles, aber er petzt nicht. Das waren auf jeden Fall so zwei Highlights. Und natürlich, die Anwesenden haben es natürlich auch mitbekommen, jeder hat es ja eigentlich schon mitbekommen, dass ich dann auch mit ein paar Leuten an unserem Camp noch eine Firma gegründet habe. Ja, Fehlkaufpunkt bis Freak Show wird auch mit freundlicher Unterstützung von Fehlkaufpunkt bis euch heute präsentiert. Also nur Highlights, nur Highlights.
Bin ich eigentlich noch eure Marketingbeauftragte?
Was ist denn da bei, also ich meine, was ist denn da der Dreh?
Also es fing alles damit an, dass Mirko meinte, er hätte vor fünf Jahren in einem Delirium-Zustand die Domain Fehlkaufpunkt bis gekauft, ihr kennt das.
Sein einziger Fehlkaufpunkt.
Sein einziger Fehlkaufpunkt. Und er meinte auch, er hätte dir davon erzählt und du hättest gesagt, er müsste da was machen und du würdest es auch retweeten. Da werden wir nachher noch mal kurz mit euch sprechen. Und dann redet ihr darüber und wie das dann so ist. In sechs Stunden gründet man eine Firma, macht eine Webseite, Twitter-Account sofort gesperrt, neuer Twitter-Account gemacht, alles klar.
Was heißt gründet eine Firma? Also ich meine, welche Rechtsform habt ihr denn da jetzt?
Eine, die man in sechs Stunden nachts so... Was man halt so machen kann. Aber wir haben in zwei Tagen Camp mehr geschafft als Start-ups in zwei Jahren sonst. Wir haben schon 540 Visitors auf der Webseite, 29 Follower auf Twitter, das letzte Mal gecheckt. Und was geht da so?
Die zweite Investmentrunde schon durch?
Na ja, wir haben schon mit Investoren gesprochen. Sieht gut aus. Aber also...
Ich hab bestimmt einen Grund, dass du bisher noch nichts zu einem eigentlichen Business-Modell gesagt hast.
Also wir wollten erst mal das Minimal Viable Product haben, Webseite, Firmenphilosophie, wir sind auch ein Traditionsunternehmen aus Mildenberg. Strukturschwache Regionen. Und wir sind da das Leuchtturmprojekt jetzt sozusagen. Na ja, das kommt Quartal 5. Erstmal haben wir überlegt, wir machen jetzt erstmal ein Linktauschprogramm, um andere Leute von der Reichweite, von Fehlkauf.bis, profitieren zu lassen. Also wenn auch ihr eine Webseite habt, die vielleicht so einen kleinen Reichweitenboost braucht, sagt Bescheid. Wir vermieten auch Subdomains und sind alle noch frei. Also wer jetzt als erstes zusagt, kriegt auch einen besonders günstigen Preis, bevor die Massenhistorie losgeht.
Also zum Beispiel Tellerkopfschraube. Punkt.
Aber das, nee, eher nicht.
Da hast du dir gerade anders überlegt.
Also, kauft man was bei Fehlkauf, oder ist das mehr so eine Art?
Wir vermieten Subdomains. Wenn das aber unter einem gewissen Mindestbestellwert bleibt, dann schreibt man darauf vielleicht Werbung dazu. Alle Amazon-Produkte sortiert nach Fehlkauf.
Was heißt sortiert nach Fehlkauf?
Also einen Stern oder weniger. Denn wir wollen die Leute ja nicht beim Einkaufen mit ihrer Unsicherheit zurücklassen, ob es jetzt ein Fehlkauf ist oder nicht. Bei uns gibt es 100% garantiert Fehlkauf. Wenn wir es noch schaffen, morgen wollen wir noch so ein B2B-Login-Button machen mit Captures. Das erste Capture 4x4, das zweite 5x5, das dritte 9x9 ist eigentlich ein Memoriespiel. Wenn ihr es dann geschafft habt, da durchzukommen, dann gibt es einen exklusiven Zugang zu unserem PHPBB-Fehlkaufexperten-Forum, wo man sich dann austauschen kann.
Ist das dann bei euch eigentlich die Business-Lounge?
Ja, warum nicht? Unser CEO hat das Motto, wir nehmen alles. Es gibt auch Aufkleber nachher. Ich sehe es schon in den Gesichtern. Ja, das ist meine Highlight bisher.
Das war auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut. Jetzt ihr.
Mein tolles Erlebnis, ich habe mir jetzt, ich kann es ja jetzt gestehen, wir sind da unter uns, ich habe mir jetzt zum ersten Mal im Leben einen Campingstuhl gekauft und ich liebe den. Ich stelle den einfach irgendwo hin, gucke mir nachts Dinge an, weil die Leute so für bunte Sachen machen, oder auch tagsüber, wenn es außerhalb der Dust-Zone ist. Ich sitze dann halt einfach so, ich will da einfach nur sitzen.
Mit Tellerkopfschraube oder ohne?
Nee, der ist noch mobil. Aber ich habe gerade schon deine Tellerkopfschraube schon geeilt.
Meiner hat mehr Gewinde.
Früher war mehr Gewinde.
Das ist noch eine neue Qualität. Nicht einfach nur rumlaufen hier, sondern rum sitzen.
Genau, das ist nämlich jetzt sozusagen das Detail, was du vielleicht noch mal herausarbeiten solltest, dass du halt nicht nur einen Campingschuhl hast, weil das ist ja jetzt nichts Besonderes. Du bist wahrscheinlich der Einzige auf dem Camp, der die ganze Zeit mit dem Campingschuhl herumläuft.
Andere fahren mit ihrem Campingschuhl umher.
Ja, andere fahren und so, aber...
Gibt es da noch andere?
Ja, bei Huckelen, der Business Lounge, sind ja immer genug Stühle. Da muss ich immer meinen eigenen mitbringen. Das ist so ein bisschen der Fehlkorb von denen, zu wenig Stühle.
Ja, wir hatten keine Ahnung, dass das so schnell wächst alles.
Vielleicht bräuchte es ein innovatives Produkt, so ein Campingschuhl, den man als Backpack tragen kann, der per Beschleunigungs-Sensor automatisch feststellt, wenn man sich nach hinten fallen lässt und dann automatisch einen Campingschuhl unter dem eigenen hin dann ausfährt.
Oder Liege. Ich arbeite schon an neuen Varianten fürs nächste Camp, wo man die dann auch so ein bisschen so Fernsehsessel-mäßig so ausklappen kann. Sowas soll es geben.
Leben im 21.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig exciting, aber ich find's mal ganz nett. Einfach mal so lange rumsitzen, wie's einem gefällt. Im Märchenwald hab ich neulich mal eine Weile rumgesessen. Die haben sehr komischen Hängematten weggemacht vom letzten Mal und irgendwelche Camper dahingelassen. Was? Jedenfalls, wenn mich dann einfach mit dem Stuhl in den Märchenwald gesetzt, das fand ich ganz okay. Ich kann das nur empfehlen. Mit Stuhl abends rumgehen.
Mit Cappingstuhl.
Stuhlgänge machen.
Man muss vielleicht das Licht generell erwähnen. Ich finde, das ist einfach so jeden Abend aufs Neue ein Highlight, hier runter zu laufen, die Lichter zu sehen, irgendwie auch mal auf diesen Hügel hoch zu stapfen und zu sehen, dass einfach jeder Nerd mindestens eine, wenn nicht 100 gefüllte Lampen dabei hat. Das ist einfach so schön beleuchtet hier. Also sowohl die professionelle Beleuchtung, als auch das, was ihr alle mitschleppt. Das ist, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich da nicht satt sehen.
Aber auch da muss man sagen, viele Leute scheinen diese Laser-Installation da hinten noch nicht gesehen zu haben. Bei den informierten Freak Show-Hörern ist das wahrscheinlich nicht so, aber falls es doch die eine oder andere Seele gibt, die noch nicht, da hinten Gate 2 rausgehen zu diesem Hafenbecken, das wir es geschafft haben, guckt euch mal die Laser-Show da an.
Ich habe beim Zert davon gehört.
An dieser Stelle muss ich sagen, Gate Arabisch 2. Und ein Schlaumeyer kam nicht auf die Idee, hier noch ein Gate Römisch 2 anzubringen.
Okay, Gate Arabisch 2.
Und sucht mal Steine, falls ihr noch welche findet, und werft sie ins Wasser.
Aber nicht auf die Laser?
Doch.
Also doch.
Also nicht auf den Laser, der in das Wasser leuchtet, sondern auf die Wasseroberfläche.
Also der Laser bricht sich am Wasser, und wenn du halt einen Stein reinschmeißt und dann Wellen erzeugst, dann wirkt dieser Laser quasi wie so eine Spektroskopie. Also dann wird quasi diese Welle direkt auf die Lichtwelle übertragen und dementsprechend trippelt sich das dann aus.
Und da drüben ist auch ziemlich staubfreie Zone, muss ich an dieser Stelle mal sagen. Es entwickelt sich hier echt zum Problem. Also man hört das häufiger so in dem Bereich dort.
Apropos Staub. Mein schönstes Erlebnis auf dem Camp bisher war Staubsaugen. Ich hab da mal was vorbereitet.
Der Original Markita, wie heißt das Teil?
Staubsauger. Natürlich mit einem Markita-Akku.
Ja.
Ich dachte gerade, da wäre eine Flaschenhalterung dran.
Ich habe keine Flasche. Ich weiß gar nicht, wieso.
Du bist jetzt hier die ganze Zeit übers Camp gelaufen und hast dir den ganzen Staub aufgesaugt?
Aber ich mach jetzt hier nicht auf, okay?
Ist das mit Filter oder ohne? Also mit Beutel oder?
Heberfilter, genau.
Das klären wir später.
Alles klar.
Und du solltest den definitiv gut säubern, bevor du nach Hause fährst.
Ist nicht meiner.
Also Staubsauger beim Zelten fällt ja dann schon ganz klar in die Kategorie Glamping. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diesen Begriff schon gehört habt, aber das ist jetzt der neue Trend.
Was ist das?
Na, Glorious Camping, also Luxus Camping. Glamorous Camping.
Die Freak Show Schickeria weiß Bescheid.
Ihr wisst genau, also glamouröses Camping.
Eine gute Powerbank ist auch von Vorteil.
Ja, das hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Wenn das Phone mal wieder alle ist. Wir können weitermachen.
Also du hast auch die Makita Powerbank. Hast du noch irgendwas anderes?
Nur normale Sachen.
Hast du das Waffeleisen?
Jaja, ich wollte grad fragen. Gibt es ein Waffeleisen?
Gab's nicht auch das Waffeleisen? Haben wir das nicht?
Nein, ich habe davon gesprochen, dass das noch fehlt.
Ich hab da schon ausufernd hinterher recherchiert, aber bin bisher noch nicht auf das optimale Produkt gekommen, was man haben will.
Ja, weil eins meiner schönsten Erlebnisse hier war, ich stand beim Wok in der Waffelschlange, so fünf Minuten, und dann kam jemand raus, kennt sich jemand mit Waffeleisen aus. Und schwupp, stand ich eine Stunde im Wok und hab Waffeln gemacht. Industriewaffelautomaten sind echt was Schönes. Also Waffeleisen.
Jetzt will sie eins von mir zum Geburtstag haben.
Ein Industriewaffeleisen.
Für 1200 Euro.
Nein, sie kosten nur zwischen 200 und 300 Euro und man kann Doppelwaffel machen.
Ist quasi geschenkt.
Aber die sind wirklich gut. Also ich hatte neulich auch auf einer Party, da stand auch so ein Teil von so einem Party-Service. Die haben einfach bemerkenswert wenige der Nachteile, die die anderen immer haben.
Ja, vor allem dieses extrem nervtötende Piepen, was meins hat. Also es klingt schlimmer als ne Alarmanlage. Die piepen einfach gar nicht.
Die machen einfach die Waffel fertig und dann ist sie fertig.
Genau. Und hat's dann im Gefühl.
Und welche vor?
Ich hab im Prinzip drei bedient. Zwei hatten so diese belgischen dicken, ordentlichen und ein großes, herzförmiges, rundes, mit relativ dünnen Waffeln.
Das will man nicht.
Wie viel hast du denn dann gegessen?
Wie Essen.
Nein, Thala ist nur bei Friedel Richter bekannt, weil sie immer Pommes isst.
Grundnahrungsmittel sind Pommes mit Aioli.
Aber die Waffeln hast du nur gemacht.
Ich hab am Ende eine gegessen. Das Problem ist, dass in dem Waffelteig, was das Bock macht, ist halt Mate drin.
Was? Das wusste ich noch nicht.
Die stellen dort Massenvernichtungswaffeln hin.
Und das kommt bei mir nicht so gut.
Today I learned.
Ich hab für andere Waffeln gemacht. Und es gab leider den Vorfall, dass eine unserer Waffeln geklaut wurde. Wir hatten sie kurz abgestellt. Und das nächste Mal, als wir geguckt haben, war es nur noch die Hälfte da.
Ich hab nicht mal die ganze geklaut.
Nein, es waren mehrere Waffeln. Es waren fiese Waffeln, die wir unterwegs. Aber sie waren halt auch gut. Insofern kann ich es verstehen, wurde mir gesagt. Mehr Waffeln.
Habt ihr noch einen Beitrag zum Glamping?
Das würde, glaube ich, ausufern.
Ja, natürlich. Also ich habe auch eine neue Produktentdeckung gemacht. Als Wohnwagenbetreiber. Betreiber?
Super Glamping.
Ich betreibe den.
Erfolgreich?
Sehr erfolgreich.
Das kann man wirklich so sagen.
Genau. Und man taucht dann auch immer wieder ganz automatisch in neue Produktwelten oder auch schon in alte Produktwelten auf, die so Facetten aufweisen, an die man bisher noch gar nicht gedacht hat.
Wasserhähne zum Beispiel.
Wasserhähne, da geht das schon ein bisschen genau richtig im Thema. Beziehungsweise generell das Problem von Wasser. Weil du hast ja diesen Vorteil, dass du einen Tank hast, aber der ist ja dann irgendwann auch leer und dann musst du den wieder befüllen und das ist ein Problem.
Das ist zumindest der einfache Tank, der viel schwierige Tank ist, der leer ankommt und immer voller wird.
Ja, Gardener auf große Klinke und jetzt bist du.
Naja, so ähnlich. Also ich meine, man kann natürlich dann einen Kanister voll machen, nur danach musst du ja diesen Kanister irgendwie in deinen Frischwassertank reinbekommen und dann Gravitation und dieser ganze Kram. Also hebst du dann irgendwie so einen 20 Kilo Kanister an und stehst da irgendwie wie so ein bekloppter 5 Minuten, bis das Ding da irgendwie reingluckert und es macht irgendwie überhaupt gar keinen Spaß. Pumpe, genau. Und was gibt es da tolles? Es gibt eine...
Makita.
Ja, Moment, Moment.
Wir sagen, wir ziehen so häufig Produkte an, um das Wok zu dissen, also nur das Bescheid.
Ne, es gibt tatsächlich eine Gardena, also das gibt es jetzt nicht nur von Gardena, aber ich hab die von Gardena jetzt mir noch schnell besorgt, eine Gardena Bohrmaschinenpumpe, die du einfach so mit Gardena-Steckern dazwischen in deinen Schlauch reinsteckst, und dann hast du da so einen Stab, da machst du dann deinen Makita-Bohrmaschinenpumper drauf, genau, in dem Fall so, und dann kannst du einfach so mit der Bohrmaschine da so stehen, also mit dem Akkuschrauber so, und du pumst. Und schon ist der Granista im Tank.
Die Zukunft.
Das ist wirklich Glamping.
Hat noch Becher.
Glamping Deluxe. Ich bin begeistert.
Kannst du nicht gleich so einen Aquariumpumpe an dein Camper anschließen, an die 12 Volt, dann brauchst du nicht immer deinen Akkuschrauber noch und so weiter.
Aquariumpumpe.
Na gut, es muss ja auch irgendwo herkommen, das Wasser.
Ja gut, aber dann sparst du deinen Akkuschrauber. Mit dem Rumbasteln.
Ja, aber es geht dir dann nicht schnell.
Du machst dir einen Kanister und dann drückst du deinen Camper auf den Knopf und dann zieht er sich da rein.
Und wenn du deinen Akkuschrauber auf Linkslauf drehst, kannst du auch das Problem mit dem anderen Tank lösen.
Aber am besten hast du da noch eine zweite Pumpe.
Und ein Schlag.
So, ich möchte noch weitere Highlights vom Camp hören. Michi, was ist dir denn bisher wieder erfahren?
Mein Highlight war auf jeden Fall, als ich das erste Mal zu zweit den Weg vom Zelt zu den Duschen gefunden hab. Und dann noch den richtigen, nämlich diesen Wunderland-Duschen mit Pflanzen und Sitzgelegenheiten.
10 Applaus für das Duschwunderland.
Genau, und auf dem Weg hab ich sogar noch den verschollenen Kicker gefunden. Und ich glaube, jemand, um den wir gesucht hatten. Also es war so erfolgreich, bin ich sonst nie. In Orientierungsdingen.
Ich hab dieses Duschwunderland noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ja, weil immer ich den seh.
Ja, nicht weil ich den seh, ich hab da die andere Dusche ja auch noch.
Man kann da großartig davor auch rumliegen auf diesen schwarzen, die sind dann ganz beheizt, macht den Bauch warm.
Und sonnenbebrandet sind die auch.
Ist das bei dem Wetter überhaupt was, was man will?
Weil man sonst friert.
Ja, da ist die Lounge irgendwie ganz praktisch. Ich hab das gestern dann mal ausprobiert, wie dieser Lounge zum Abend, wenn es kalt wird. Also man schwitzt so ein bisschen sehr arg da drin irgendwie. Aber ist auch sehr schön gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr die schon gesehen? Die Lounge, die Chemistry Lounge?
Fragezeichen?
Die Disse.
Ja. Nur von außen.
Hinten, kurz vorm Family Village gegenüber.
Mit der alten Aufbereitung.
Genau, alte Aufbereitung, genau, das steht da drüben. An der Rakete vorbei, genau. Sehr zu empfehlen, sehr schön dekoriert auch.
Ich hab auch einen Sessel gesehen, der stand vor so einem Generator und da stand dran, Bredenort, der warme Ort.
Das sind auch Highlights. Also das Signature auf dem Camp ist wirklich grandios. Also ich hab so viele geile Schilder entdeckt.
Du musst doch jetzt dieses Mikrofon an den Mund heranhalten.
Ich muss hier noch mehr reinbeißen. Ich könnte es auch einfach weiter aufdrehen.
Nein, dann pfeifst du Pfeife.
Ich sagte gerade, das Signature ist grandios. So viele geile Schilder gesehen. Klassiker auch dabei, aber auch sehr viele schöne neue Schilder.
Was sind zum Beispiel?
Projektionsleiter zum Beispiel.
Die Projektionsleiter.
Defy Vibrator? Den hab ich noch nicht gesehen. Klingt interessant.
Ich fand The World's Largest Imseacatcher nicht schlecht.
Der ist auch nett, ja.
Der stand an dem LTE-Mast. An dem LTE-Mast.
Was ich zumindest sehr cool finde, wir haben ja auch einen waschechten Telekomiker hier unter uns, nämlich den Peter Schmidt. Der häufiger schon mal dieses Kästchen aufgemacht hat. Für Interessierte. Und der fand das Schild auch ziemlich geil. Hat das auch gleich erstmal fotografiert. Welches Kästchen hat der aufgemacht? Vorne am Markt steht ja noch so ein LTE-Turm von einer Telekom. So ein Temporal-Ramen. Also so ein Container auf Rädern mit Mast obendrauf. Und ja, der geht gelegentlich so ein, zwei Mal am Tag. Ein, zwei Mal am Tag geht der auf. Da steht der Peter dann da, der hat einen Schlüssel dafür. Und dann kann man da reingucken und ihm Fragen stellen. So, finde ich mal einen ganz guten Support auch seitens der Telekom.
Wo wir gerade bei Internet sind. Du warst ja diesmal etwas beteiligt bei der Früher-Erschließung des Camps, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, aber nur bei der. Also Knock bleibt Knock. Das fasse ich nicht an. Nee, aber wir haben mal ein bisschen Aufbaunetz und werden auch Abbaunetz machen mit der Funk-Technik, die ich ja in Berlin jetzt schon seit eineinhalb Jahren da bespiele vom Funk-Turm und wir funken auch mal hier rüber. Fernsehturm, vom Fernsehturm am Alex. Und wir funken auch hier rüber, because we can, hat sich so ergeben.
Flache Erde, kein Problem.
Nee, der Witz ist, wir hatten natürlich vorher schon mal geguckt, so runde Erde und so, aber da weißt man natürlich nie, ob da irgendwelche Hügel oder Häuser dazwischen sind. Jedenfalls haben wir nicht dran geglaubt. Und als wir die andere Funk-Strecke, die ja auch noch besteht, die wir gemacht haben, als wir die gescoutet haben, saß ein Kollege von mir oben auf dem Schornstein drauf, in der schönsten Abendsonne, und schickte mir ein Handyfoto mit der Bemerkung, du glaubst nicht, was ich hier sehe. Und was man dann sah, war ganz hinten im Dunst den oberen Teil des Fernsehturms am Alexanderplatz.
Aber ich finde nicht nur unbedingt der obere Teil, so dieses letzte Stück, sondern der war halt sehr, sehr klar sichtbar. Auch von unterhalb der Kugel war noch relativ viel zu sehen.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, wenn wir die jetzt schon sehen, dann müssen wir wohl, dann haben wir ein bisschen geknuspert und gerechnet und so und haben da eben auch nochmal ein Lick hingebastelt.
Und wie viel?
Abteilung Because We Can. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt sinnvoll wäre oder so, aber Because We Can.
Ja, Because, was konntet ihr denn können?
Meinst du Bits?
Ja.
Ähm, im Mittel so 380 Megabit.
380 Megabit.
Ich weiß, da würden Leute für töten auf manchen Dörfern. Also auch wenn es jetzt so ein... Und wir reden ja gerade mal viel über Klima und Wetter und so. Und einer der Aspekte, die dabei sehr interessant waren, wo wir echt nicht mitgerechnet haben. Wir wussten, dass das Ding, wenn es jetzt so richtig sindflutartig regnet, wie es jetzt so in den letzten Wochen gerne mal passiert, dass das Ding dann ein bisschen schwächelt oder vielleicht auch mal im Extremfall mal ausgeht. Was aber viel toller ist, ist nach dem Regen geht der so gut wie nie. Nach dem Regen haben wir so 20 Minuten lang 472 Megabit. Saubere Luft, also beziehungsweise sonst dreckige Luft und auch warme Luft. Und nach dem Regen ist die kühl und sauber und dann kriegen wir da 472 Megabit durch. War ein bisschen unerwarteter Effekt, aber ist nachweisbar. Aber ja.
Wenn der Äther also durchgewaschen wird, dann ist es auch das irgendwie besser.
Wie heißt das Wasser?
Roddy, wie heißt das Wasser?
Grander Wasser.
Das ist Grander-Regen sozusagen. Das ist informierter Regen. Spätestens wenn wir durch die Bits durchballern, ist das informierter Regen.
Aber hallo, der weiß richtig Bescheid.
Der weiß voll Bescheid. Größtenteils verschlüsselt leider, aber naja, Bescheid ist Bescheid.
Information ist Information.
Genau.
Das war so ein bisschen ein Bastelprojekt und das ist ganz nett, macht das ganz lustig, mit den ganzen Nebeneffekten und allmöchen. Und ja, wir haben auch noch eine andere Strecke gebaut, wo Leute noch viel mehr vertöten würden. Die andere Strecke, die ich eigentlich scouting wollte, ist nämlich die 10G-Strecke nach Gransee. Die geht auch über 11 Kilometer.
Ja, bei schönem Wetter.
Sonst wird da wieder sehr, sehr viel regnen. Also wenn es jetzt hier regnet, dann habt ihr hier sehr informierte Landstriche zwischen hier und Gransee.
Das kann nicht schaden. Nein.
Wir können ja vor dem 1. September die Strahlen noch ein bisschen rumdrehen, also in alle Richtungen und nochmal gucken, dass wir da noch was informieren.
So, wenn wir über Highlights sprechen. Musik ist hier irgendwie ein Thema, habe ich so den Eindruck. Also ihr werdet ja sicherlich schon davon bekommen haben, von dieser hippen Electropunk-Fraktion, Systemabsturz hier irgendwie mittlerweile glaube ich jeden Tag irgendwo ein Konzert geben. Ich weiß nicht, wo sie heute waren, aber das hatten wir ja auch schon hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Und jetzt wurde mir noch ein geheimes Video zugespielt.
Auf den Schirm.
Mit einem Audio-Podcast.
Mit einem weiteren Musikprodukt aus Kamp-Landen.
Ist es das POG?
Das POG hat wieder zugeschlagen. Und weltexklusiv, nur hier bei der Freak Show für euch.
Jetzt hat's geblubbt, oder?
Oder hab ich keinen Ton? Ich hab keinen Ton.
Das geht nicht, Entschuldigung.
Weil ich ein fucking Profi bin.
Das tut mir leid.
Fehlkauf.
Ja.
Wieso ist hier kein Ton?
Das wird teuer.
Notlösung.
Wir könnten die anderen Highlights durchgehen.
Was? Dann machen wir das so?
Ich hab's total geil.
Wieso spielt auch dieses bekloppte Messages diese Scheiße in dem fucking Browser ab?
Das Schöne ist, das sind die Momente, die die Hörer sonst nie sehen.
Tim weigert sich immer Video- oder Fotoübertragung zu machen.
Ja, das ist ja auch.
Schalten Sie auf das nächste Mal wieder ein.
Der Ton ist sofort da. Und jetzt werde ich nochmal ganz vorsichtig sein und nicht auf das falsche Feld klicken. Ihr wisst alles besser, ich weiß. Ich bin nur ein armer Podcast. Kann mal irgendeiner mal einen Witz machen oder so?
Ich kann dir noch so von meinem schönsten Camperlebnis erzählen. Für mich ist das das erste Camp. Für wen ist das hier noch das erste Mal hier? Okay, jetzt gehen so mittelfiele Arme hoch. Ich bin mit Familie hier, mit Kind. Mit Kind ist ganz großartig. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch vor Kinder zugelegt habt. Ihr solltet das euch dringend machen vor dem nächsten Camp. Das macht sehr viel Spaß, hier mit Kindern rumzutrauen.
Was ich damit sagen will, wenn ihr auch sonst keine...
Oder auf dem Camp, ihr habt noch eine Nacht.
Fürs nächste Camp, leiht euch ein.
Ihr könnt auch einfach irgendwo eins drei vor mitnehmen.
Das ist hier leider alles total klasse.
Schnell den Makita Defibrillator.
Wir haben ja noch ein Headset mehr.
Ich hab ein Fietchen, was war das für ein Maul?
Das ist die goldene Regel.
Also, so verkackt haben wir es ja noch nie, ne?
Das war alles vorbereitet.
Tim, wir sollten mal wieder am Max reden.
Ich buhle erst mal, redet ihr mal weiter.
Ich meld mich, wenn ich mich nicht sicher bin. Er scheint sich folge auch bei Fehlkauf jetzt an.
Das exklusive Drama-Doku-Video dazu. Ihr macht jetzt mal die Sendung, ich bereite alles vor und danach tun wir alles so, als hätten wir nichts gesehen.
Hast du danach noch einen Prö-Misty für uns?
Mal schauen, hier müsst ihr es dran sein.
Ja, ich finde, Michi hat eine total coole Maskierung.
Ich würde sagen, dass man mich nicht mehr erkennt. Ich habe ein Kind erschreckt.
Das reicht.
Gute Basis.
Ich hoffe, es war nicht deins, Max.
Wo kann man sich denn unkenntlich machen?
Man kann sich unkenntlich machen. Ich habe es gemacht an einer Stelle, wo es nicht so passend war. Am Hafen gibt es ein kleines, feines Restaurant. Wir saßen so auf der Wiese hinter der Hochzeitsgesellschaft. Nackt gebadet wohl auch. Das war nicht ganz so passend, aber trotzdem Spaß gemacht. Bei der Dezentrale sitzt auch Sina. Die hat noch mehr von diesem Filz. Ich habe hier auch noch mehr von diesem Filz, falls einer gerne möchte. Er möchte Filz-Tape und es ist scheinbar gut, um nicht erkannt zu werden von Kameras, Gesichtserkennung im Laufe des Prozesses. Allerdings hat sie gesagt, vielleicht ist es auch mehr so ein symbolischer Akt, der sensibilisieren soll.
Wie ist das denn mit deinem Telefon?
Kannst du dein Telefon anlocken?
Mein Telefon kann ich noch anlocken. Aber ich habe gerade gelernt, das hat ja auch so tiefen Informationen und so. Also dafür ist ja eh nicht gedacht.
Das funktioniert dann.
Ja, es funktioniert. Also das hat noch nie so gut geklappt, wie mit dem Tape drauf, ehrlich gesagt. Kurz ist das nicht so sinnvoll. Oh, Faker. Aber wie gesagt, das hat ja andere Informationen. Ich müsste es jetzt irgendwie noch mal mit einer anderen Kamera ausprobieren.
Und wo kann ich mir jetzt das Capture runterladen dafür?
Sie hatten mir ein bisschen was erklärt. Man muss scheinbar hier diese Gegend, um die Augen und die Nase, die sind wohl...
Wie ist das denn mit diesen Pickelpflastern?
Ich fand auch ein bisschen ärgerlich. Ich meine, ich hab ja zwei, drei dicke Pickel, die man auch mal hätte überkleben können. Aber nein, die sind überall anders hinbeklebt. Nur nicht drauf, die Pickel drauf.
Welche Pickelpflastern? Ach nee, das ist dieses Beatmungsding. Man kann doch irgendwas über die Nase kleben. Vielleicht ist es auch was für einen Staub.
Ich glaube, sie meinte, dieser Teil in der Mitte, der so aussieht wie ein Dreieck, der sei so richtig... Eine Pyramide. Ich hab gesagt Clitoris. Ist am Treffensten, glaub ich. Genau, der durchbricht wohl dieses Muster von Augen und Nase. Aber da sind also wirklich... Vielleicht lieber mal zu Kommune und zur Dezentrale gehen. Da liegen auch noch so Flyer aus, aber die können das besser erklären. Asymmetrie soll auch noch gut sein. Deswegen wohl hier... Ich seh mich ja selbst nicht. Das ist doch besser so. Ja, die Reaktion... Mir wurde gesagt, ich bin sichtbar und unsichtbar zugleich. Aber die Leute, zu denen ich das dann gesagt hab, die meinten eher nur sichtbar.
Aber man erkennt dich im Nachhinein nicht wieder. Also wenn du das abnimmst, haben die Leute dich vermutlich nicht mehr so im Gedächtnis.
Aber wie hast du es damit geschafft, ein Kind zu erschrecken? Also komisch sieht es jetzt ja nicht aus damit.
Hand ich auch. Ich weiß nicht. Ich hab kurz geschrien. Hatte mich nicht erwartet.
Also ich find Roddy mit seinem Einhauen ein bisschen erschreckender manchmal.
Du bist so ein ganz niedliches Einhauen.
Wo Tim jetzt so ein bisschen abgelenkt ist, meint ihr, ich könnte vom Zert erzählen?
Ja, der hört halt nichts zu. Er kann doch vom Blut reden.
Erzähl mal uns vom Zert.
Ich hab ja der Nitti versprechen müssen, dass ich nicht arbeite auf dem Camp.
Hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Genau, ich habe nicht gearbeitet, zumindest nicht für die Außenweltarbeit. Dafür hab ich mich als Zertengel eingetragen und war jetzt quasi das erste Mal im Zerteam. Ich muss sagen, es war grandios. Sowohl total cooles Team, also wirklich nette Leute, die super bereitwillig anderen was erklären und sich Mühe geben. Ich hab z.B. jetzt gelernt, wie man Tubos legt. Kein Nahrungstubus, der ganz tief geht, aber zumindest...
Also überleg dir das nochmal, Tim.
Mach mal schneller mit dem Video.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt immer noch ein bisschen Angst, neben dir zu schlafen.
Aber du musst dich ersticken.
Hat's einen HEPA-Filter dann auch?
Das war echt cool. Ich hab sowohl das Gelände sehr gut kennengelernt als Laufschicht bzw. Cat-Car-Schicht, wenn man in dem Tretroller durch die Gegend fährt und sie alles in Ruhe anguckt. Und bestimmt so 5-10 Mal pro Schicht nach einem Pflaster gefragt wird. Aber es ist erstaunlich wenig richtig krasse Sachen passiert.
Was war dein interessantester Einsatz? Oder ist das ein Datenschutz?
Ich nenne ja keine Namen. Das, was mich tatsächlich am längsten beschäftigt hat, wir hatten jemanden mit so ursprünglich relativ kleinen Verletzungen an den Fingerkuppen. So am Außenrand, da wo man gerne mal ranknibbelt.
Warte mal, Tim, setz mal bitte die Kopfhörer an. Also ich kenn die Geschichte deswegen.
Das interessante war, dass er schon sechs Tage auf dem Acker war und das Zeug nicht desinfiziert hatte. Und so an beiden Händen jeweils einem Finger ordentliche dicke Entzündungen hatte. Und der kam tatsächlich in einer meiner ersten Schichten an. Ich hab die Finger gesehen und dachte mir, da darf ich nicht ran, weil ich ein Ersthelfer bin. Hab das an den Paramedik geschickt. Das sind dann so Rettungssanitäter und welche mit höherer Ausbildung, die auch Medikamente geben dürfen. Der hat sich das angeguckt, wir holen mal einen Arzt. Der Arzt meinte dann, wir schicken den direkt zum Handchirurg. Er war dann beim Handchirurg und jetzt schaut alles super aus.
Wie, so was habt ihr hier?
Nein, extern. Wir machen keine größeren OP's. Ich weiß, wohin.
Wir machen keine größeren OP's, aber nur die kleinen. Direkt unter dem Hals amputieren und so.
Wenn sich jemand die Tellerkopfschraube in den Fuß gefahren hat.
Passiert öfter, als man denkt.
Clamping Jesus?
Aber die meisten Sachen waren tatsächlich Pflaster, Blasen, aufgeschürfte Wunden. Also relativ harmlose und man hatte viel Gelegenheit, Sachen zu lernen.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch nochmal ein spezielles Setting. Hier haben wahrscheinlich die Ärzte auch mal Zeit, wenn jemand interessiert ist, oder nicht nur unbedingt Ärzte, wahrscheinlich auch ein Rettungs-Sanee, dir etwas zu erklären, wenn du nicht... Du bist ja nur Ersthelfer, aber du hast keine weitere Qualifikation, außer unser Anatomie-Studium, was wir irgendwie mal vor vielen Jahren hatten.
Ja, und die medizinische Forschung.
Genau, und die medizinische Forschung. Aber da hast du ja auch eher mit neurodegenerativen Krankheiten zu tun. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das, was man hier auf dem Platz findet.
Ist auch spannend.
Naja, nicht so viele.
Ich hatte schon, fürs nächste Camp könnte ich rein theoretisch machen, ich bau irgendwo meine Kneckchen auf, mach Ganganalyse und am Ende hab ich so viele Datensätze, dass ich den Promillegrad von der Person wegkomme.
Das geht auf jeden Fall.
Seht ihr das als Arbeit?
Ja, nein, das ist Forschung.
Gibt es schon ein C3-Labor?
Oh, ja, ja, nein, es gibt C3-gelb. Die können wohl ein bisschen was. Aber...
Hast du es jetzt hier?
Lasst alle Hoffnung fahren.
Das Dumme ist, ich kann das jetzt nicht vorher testen, im Studio.
youtube.de hat er benutzt.
Das ist ein super Player. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das heißt.
Sorry.
Ja, ist das falsch?
Das werden wir gleich sehen.
Das werden wir gleich sehen, ja.
Naja, also... Oder nicht.
Geh noch mal auf uns hin.
Geh noch mal kurz. Werbung, ja, also das... So, und ich hoffe, dass wir jetzt hier Ton kriegen.
Kommt LF20 her. Kabel rein, Klappe zu, Datenverkehr. Wird Schutz gebrochen? Kommt unsere Feuerwehr. Camp in der Pampa, alte Ziegelei. Eventphone ist da, hat Feuerwehr dabei. Illegale Data Center, zerquetschen wir zu brei. Hast du was dagegen? Ruf doch die C3. Feuerwehr kommt mit Hydraulikrettungssatz. Einmal Knick Knack, Festplatte ist normal. Datenschnappen gibt's bei uns nämlich keine. Ich wähle eins und zwei, dann lernst du, was ich meine. Ich hab Feuerwehr und DSGVO. 5 Petabyte in der Hightech-Serverkammer mit Feuerwehr-Support kommt alles untern Hammer. Feuerwehr hat Geräte für jedes Gelände. Mit Hydrozylinder ist Speicherzeit ganz schnell zu Ende. Feuerwehr schützt Daten, denn die sind die guten. Hydraulikscheren, Quetschkraft, 100 Kilo Newton. Ich rufe Feuerwehr. Feuerwehr sofort zur Stelle. Blaulicht an. Martin Zorn. Wasser marsch. Löschwelle. Bist du Datensammler? Zack. Gehst du knass, mein kleiner Wutz? Heb mal bitte Seife auf. Der Boss im Knast heißt Datenschutz. Feuerwehr ist höflich und super korrekt. Immer verfügbar wie Aufbau, denkt's. Datenautobahn. Feuerwehr macht sauber. Und wenn's mal wieder brennt, rufen alle Feuerwehr. Gibt es Verletzte, holt Feuerwehr RTW. Egal, ob Hagel, Regen oder Schnee. Feuerwehr in Stadt, Dorf oder Garten kommen mit Kanone und löschen alle Daten. Dezentrales Backup bei Google. 5 Sterne. Widerstand zwecklos. Feuerwehr löscht sehr gerne. Wir wollen keine Spammer. Ohne Daten guckt ihr nur, wie ihr Schrocknelemmer. Feuerwehr hat Äxte, Uniform und Martinshorn. Feuerwehr hat nie Auer, denn Feuerwehr hat Protektoren. Festplatten, Schreddern. Feuerwehr hat Spaß. Und das allerbeste ist, Feuerwehr kann das. Feuerwehr hat Leitern und Rettungsgeräte. Feuerwehr hat riesige Wasservorräte. Feuerwehr hat Pumpen und Aggregate. Feuerwehr löscht sicher alle Fabrikate. Feuerwehr hat SKW, SLG und Datenwacht. Feuerwehr hat letztes Jahr 20 Server plattgemacht. Datensammler zittern, haben Angst vor Feuerwehr. Datensammler haben schwer. Datensammler gibt's nicht mehr.
Wenn sie jetzt noch Audio und Video sünden, dann...
Nee, das war alles perfekt gesunken. Ich kann ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen... Schon die Maus war da so ein bisschen...
Die Maus.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Da freut man sich ja ehrlich gesagt schon direkt auf dem Kongress, weil ich bin gespannt, was wir auf dem Kongress machen. Also dieses Pocken, das ist einfach der Wahnsinn immer mit ihren Musikvideos.
Ich bin jedes Mal in Angst vor der nächsten Veranstaltung.
Es sagt aber auch ein bisschen, dass ihre Technologie zunehmend einfacher zu bedienen wird.
So viel Salz!
Das erwähnt ihr schon, die Massenvernichtungswaffeln, vor allem an denen sie auch, glaube ich, mit massiv beteiligt sind, oder?
Ja, genau, es gab beim C3-Wok einen roten Buzzer und jedes Mal, wenn eine Waffel fertig war, musste man den Buzzer drücken und dann wurden randomisiert zwei Dektelefone angerufen. Die haben die Nachricht bekommen, ach, übrigens, es ist eine Waffel für euch bereit.
Wer von euch wurde angerufen?
Ja, und die sind dahin, habe ich schon gehört, und da mussten sie sich trotzdem anstellen.
So, weitere schöne Impressionen vom Camp. Wer hat denn noch irgendwas erlebt?
Soll ich nicht weiter erzählen?
Möchtest du wieder zuhören bei den blutigen Themen?
Ich weiß schon nicht.
Talas vom Zert erzählt. Lass doch mal den Dennis erzählen. Der hat bestimmt auch sein schönstes Ferienerlebnis.
Kann mich nicht erinnern.
Bist du am Beauty oder bist du ihr Frau Fun?
Alles. Nee, aber die meisten sagen ja so, Computer keinen Bock mehr, machen auf Gärtner oder was war das andere, auf mit Holz. Kennen wir ein paar Leute, die sagen, die machen nur mit Holz. Ich dachte mir jetzt schnauzevoll, habe ich Burger verkauft.
Ach echt, bei Friedrich da? Hast du nur das Geld eingenommen oder hast du die auch produziert?
Nee, produzieren war das andere. Ich mache ja immer nur Kasse.
Ich mache Kasse.
Hast du denn ein Frikadellen-Diplom? Nee, nichts hab ich.
Kasse kannst du irgendein hinstellen, da muss nix können. Da dachte ich, kann ich. Eine Minute anlernen und dann ging's.
Hat geklappt. Hast dich auch mit technischen Dingen beschäftigt?
Hier?
Wir haben uns die Badge geholt.
Ach so, ja hier.
Die Cardio.
Die brauchen wir nur zusammenschrauben. Hab ich geupdatet. Hab ich eine Uhr installiert. Die anderen konnte ich nicht lesen, deswegen hab ich mir die Digitalklok installiert. Wenn man sie gestellt hat. Ja, hab ich. 21.54 Uhr sagt sie.
Warte, die Uhr stellt sie nicht selbst?
Nächste Mal dann vielleicht. Geht aber wohl, kann man mit Bluetooth rüber schicken, meint sie von jemand, aber es kommt noch.
Ich finde, moderne Uhr könnte sich schon selbst stellen.
Ja, kommt noch. Wir können ja Bluetooth.
Wie viele Leute haben dich denn erkannt beim Burger-Verkaufen?
Nicht so viele, also, weiß nicht, zwei, drei.
Hat nicht so gewädert wie sonst.
Der Hut hat ja kein Lichter.
War ja ohne Mikro.
Ich sehe schon, das ist nicht viel zu holen. Max, wie geht es dir denn so auf dem Camp? Du bist ja sowieso... Du bist ja jetzt überhaupt wieder im Heim angekommen. Wie lange warst du jetzt im Feindesland?
Feindesland zählt Kalifornien oder ist das? Das war ja nur die Hälfte der Zeit Trumpistan. Seit 2014. Also das erste Camp, also das Camp davor, da war ich schon da, da habe ich ja sogar diesen Podcast gehört. Drüben auf dem anderen Seite, auch da gibt es das Internet. Und es ist ein... Jetzt bin ich wieder zu Hause. Tatsächlich. Also ich habe so doch ziemlich lange gefremdelt mit Berlin und mit Deutschland. Na ja, so ein halbes Jahr, keine Ahnung. Und so ein bisschen rougher Einstieg hier wieder. Aber das war sehr großartig hier.
War drüben das Internet zu gut?
Und die Leute waren nett. Das ist so, ich... Ich habe ja nie woanders als Berlin gelebt. Ich habe immer sagen lassen, dass die Berliner nicht so die allerherzlichsten Menschen sein sollen.
Was willst du damit sagen, ey?
Wir sind doch quasi die Bitter der Freundlichkeit.
Wollen Sie kicken oder kurfen?
Im Fahrrad nicht im ersten Wagen.
Die Karte nehmen wir nicht. Genau, also insofern alles toll. Alles großartig. Und wie gesagt, mit Kind, der hat heute Raketen gebaut. Ich habe die ganze Zeit andere Väter von diesem Raketenabschließgerät weg. Der hat gelötet, der hat ein Einhorn-T-Shirt bekommen. Der ist voll ausgestattet, der ist jetzt wirklich voll indoktriniert. Das geht nicht mehr weg.
Also du bist sozusagen Teilnehmer des Kids-Base?
Ja, ich renne hinterher.
Falls ihr noch nicht gemerkt habt, es gibt da ein ganzes Zelt voll mit Duplo.
Ich dachte, es würde auch Lego geben.
Lego ist die Firma und ihr erstes Produkt und Duplo ist ein anderes Produkt. Das sind nämlich die großen Legos.
Ich find die gar nicht langweilig.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen von oben herab. Diese großen Duplos haben auch was für sich.
Das ist glaube ich einfach, weil wir nie Duplo hatten, sondern immer gleich Lego.
Das gute Lego?
Ja, ich fand auch.
Früher war alles besser.
Wir hatten das, was noch ordentlich weh tat.
Duplo macht wesentlich weniger Schmerzen.
Das ist nicht abgerundet, das ist genau das gleiche, bloß halt größer.
Aber es tut nicht so weh.
Das ist nicht nur ein Nachteil.
Das glaubst du auch nur, weil du es noch nicht ausprobiert hast.
Doch, ich war in dem Zelt.
Also so im direkten Vergleich, wenn mein Barfuß drüber lauft.
Ihr könnt ja mal einen Blit-Vergleich organisieren.
Ja, ich bin schon im Kopf dabei.
Lego-Farkir-Contest im Kids-Base.
Apropos Raketen falten, löten, wie auch immer. Ich hab da zwei Sachen dazu. Eine Sache ist, der Rainer, der uns hier nicht nur die Previously macht, der kann auch das mit diesen Raketen. Und der hat Raketen aus Draht gebogen. Der hat dazu auch einen Workshop gemacht und hat mir eine davon geschenkt.
Das ist super cool.
Das ist eine aus dem Design, die anderen waren ein bisschen schwieriger, deswegen sind die nicht gebogen und gelötet worden. Das ist die einfachste von allen, die kann man sich selber biegen. Rainer hat auch die Vorlagen dazu. Die geschwungenen. Die ist schon schick. In meinem Piercing hat sie nicht reingepasst, das haben wir schon aufprobiert. Wollte nicht. Dann hatte Thala eine wunderbare Idee. Ich bin verankert hier bei der Sea-Base. Ich hab mich bei der Sea-Base um die Deko für die Main Hall gekümmert. Ich meinte, Thala, ich hab kein Budget, was kannst du mit Raumschiffen machen? Dann kam sie auf die glorreiche Idee, Raumschiffe in Origami zu falten. Unter anderem auch eine Rakete, die der Herr Pritlove nicht als die Fairy das sehen wollte, sondern als eine Krake. Das hab ich dir gar nicht erzählt, die Beleidigung. Raketen kann man auch wunderbar falten und es gibt ziemlich viele Anleitungen für die ganzen Star Wars. Genau, diese ganzen Sachen als Origami-Geschichten, die man falten kann. Dann hat mir Thala ziemlich viel geholfen bei der Seabase ein SG50-Zelt in Mülltüten zu hüllen, damit es nicht so weiß ist. Und Space Blankets sind oben in der Decke hängen, gefaltete Raumschiffe und Feridus-Raketen. Das hat ziemlich viel Spaß gemacht.
Oh ja, ich hab meine Leidenschaft für Sprühfarbe entdeckt.
Ich hoffe immer noch, dass dieses Zelt heil geblieben ist. Das werden wir dann morgen irgendwann sehen.
Ich bin aber noch am Überlegen, wie ich jetzt meine Tüte mit den ganzen Sprühfarben irgendwie nach Berlin bekomme, in den Öffentlichen.
Ich finde, du solltest auf jeden Fall mit diesen Sprühfarben irgendwie vor dem Ostbahnhof herumlaufen. Die finden das großartig.
Klacker, klacker, klacker.
Was haben sie denn da?
Also ich bin echt froh, dass sich damit in der S-Bahn niemand erwischt hat nach wie vor.
Apropos Seabase, ihr habt ja da auch diesen schönen, die Antenne.
Unseren Fernsehturm.
Der wurde heute noch mal nachdekoriert, was ich sehr, sehr nett fand. Mit einer kleinen Hommage an die Funkstrecke. Da hängt jetzt nämlich auch eine Funkstrecke oben.
Geil.
Das fand ich sehr nettlich.
Das finde ich wirklich toll.
Das Ding ist im Übrigen gar nicht so leicht, hierher zu transportieren, haben wir festgestellt.
Wer hätte es gedacht, oder?
Also der Fernsehturm, den in Berlin abzubauen, ist echt nicht so einfach, ohne dass es jemand merkt. Du hast halt so eine riesige Kugel, die ist gefertigt, ich glaube, innen aus Holz. Und dann verkleidet mit, ich weiß nicht, was alle Schichten sind, unter anderem so Spiegelfolie. Und wenn man die halt versucht anzufassen an der falschen Stelle, macht es knack. Und du hast irgendwie so ein Problem mit dem Skelett, was da drum rumgebaut ist, um die Hülle des Fernsehturms. Und das restliche Holz ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die leichteste Ladung. Ich hoffe, das Auto war nicht überladen und wir sind nicht vorschriftsmäßig unterwegs gewesen. Aber es ist halt so vom Transportieren her, du hast halt diese riesige Kugel, so ein Transporter ist nicht so groß und man muss die hängen transportieren. Das heißt, wir haben halt versucht, eine Latte zu finden, die man an die Oberkante eines Sprinters hängen konnte, um dann daran diese Kugel zu hängen. Und die wir unten dann aber noch mit so einem, wir haben so eine, was ist das denn, so ein OP-Licht, so ein altes, diese drei Lichter, das haben wir dann auch unten rangeellt, damit diese Kugel nicht die ganze Zeit hin und her meandert in dem Transporter. Also es war sehr spannend, ich bin auch froh, dass sie es überlebt hat.
Also Glück muss sie nicht zurücknehmen.
Theoretisch muss sie nicht zurücknehmen. Die hat ihre Tat, wie heißt das?
In die Entkürbigkeit-Position erreicht.
Ja genau, wir lassen sie einfach in Mildenberg. Das funktioniert ja ganz gut hier mit dem Einlagern, habe ich gehört, mit diesen Öfen. Haben sie nicht hier einen Lehmofen eingelagert?
Ja, stimmt, die haben den Lehmofen aus dem Kids Base eingelagert. Und wieder rausgeholt, und so weit ich weiß auch, wie da ein Betrieb genommen wird.
In einem Ofen eingelagert.
I heard you like Ofens.
Sehr meta.
Ja, das mag ich auch sehr. Was ist denn so euer Eindruck von dem Camp an sich, also in seiner Gesamtheit?
Du hast uns gar nicht dein schönstes Erlebnis erzählt.
Ja, ich grübel noch.
Das war doch seine Makita-Pumpe.
Das war ein persönliches Erlebnis. Wie findet ihr sozusagen die Gesamtkonstellation des Camps? Profimäßig.
Jeder kommt hier, macht so sein Ding, alles geht ratzfatz. Und jeder ist irgendwie beschäftigt und zieht so sein Ding hoch. Also es ist weniger chaotisch als man denkt.
Da kann man nicht meckern.
Wer denkt jetzt? Meist jetzt alle, einschließlich der Teil?
Ja, es sind alle mega vorbereitet. Alle haben irgendwie voll viel dabei, sind ausgestattet hier, glamping. Also jeder hier, gerade Lettini hat schon, also nächste Camp macht Lettie so einen riesen Burg, hat sie erzählt, mit Alm.
Ne Burg?
Nicht. Ach so, ein Village.
Größer auf jeden Fall als jetzt. Und alle denken wahrscheinlich auch so, beim nächsten Mal wird aufgerüstet.
Ja genau, das muss man vielleicht mal dazu sagen. Was ich so bezeichnen fand, war ein Gespräch, was wir in der Business Lounge von Huckel hatten, das nicht mehr so richtig nur noch um Technik geht, sondern alle hierher kommen, um sich wohlzufühlen. Also man bringt die Technik mit, es ist aber weniger geworden, und es ist dieser Komfortfaktor, den alle irgendwie mitschleppen, sei es irgendwie die faltbare Küche oder Küchenschrank, wo ich erst dachte, boah, ganz schön spießig, aber jetzt ist das doch ganz geil. So ein geordeter Küchenschrank, ich bin schon am Überlegen, ob ich ihm gefälscht habe, einen Kleiderschrank nächstes Mal mitlegen. Nur für die Ordnung, also ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich finde es irgendwie schön, alles geordnet zu haben.
Den Grund herausfindend, warum sie es geordnet hat.
Als Therapiemaßnahme.
Ja genau, um es ein bisschen so einzunorden.
Let it condo.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall erstaunlich, was die Leute hier so hochziehen für fünf Tage.
Zum Beispiel den Maibaum.
Der Maibaum ist auch wirklich der Wahnsinn. Dieser blinkende oder was auch immer.
Da hab ich schon im Vorbeigehen gehört, versuche den zu enttern oder zu einkassieren. Weil der ist ja wohl aus Bayern oder aus Franken.
Nee, nicht aus Franken. Franken waren es bestimmt.
Also ich meine, das gehört ja dazu.
Ich bliefe an irgendwelchen Leuten vorbei, die gerade Pläne schmiedeten, diesen Maibaum dazu.
Ja ich bin gespannt, wann ich ihn das nächste Mal woanders sehe.
Naja, aber Maibaume muss man klauen, das stimmt schon.
Oh, beim Aufbauen ist er durchgebrochen.
Dann kann man ihn nicht mehr klauen oder was?
Das sah dramatisch aus, aber könnte offenbar wieder gefixt werden.
Sah grad ganz gut aus auf jeden Fall.
Darf ich auch mal was sagen, was jetzt nicht so jubelmäßig ist?
Nein.
Was, Kritik?
Nein, nein. Kritik ist hier nicht erwünscht.
Ich hab ja nur wegen der Funkbuzzlei auch so ein bisschen diese Aufbaunummer miterlebt seit etlichen Wochen. Und die sind auch schon ziemlich cool, muss man sagen. Die haben auch wirklich, da wird auch nochmal sehr viel mehr Zeit dran verbunden. Die Leute, die so seit Anfang, die so seit 5. August hier sind oder davor sogar noch. Und da fiel mir jetzt schon auf, dass je mehr Leute hier sind, desto mehr wird hier dann aber auch verwaltet und verwalten gespielt und Spielregeln aufgestellt und desto mehr Leute laufen auch rum, die dich auf Spielregeln hinweisen und so weiter und so fort. Also es wird sozusagen auch ein bisschen steilverlässig, ein bisschen deutscher. Ich glaube, das muss vielleicht auch so sein, weil je mehr Leute du anschleppst, desto mehr Pappnasen schleppst du auch an. Zwangsläufig. Wobei du hier schon eine ziemlich Pappnasen- und arschlochfreie Zone frisst. Aber es ist mir denn schon aufgefallen, dass sozusagen je mehr Leute hier ankamen, desto mehr Leute liefen hier rum, die sich wichtig machten.
Dieses Bobbycar darf wirklich keine 30-Stunden-Kilometer fahren.
Auch nicht im Kidspace. Ich hoffe, ihr geht bitte nicht auf diesen Turm, wo das Pock drauf stand. Da steht explizit, dass man da nicht draufgehen sollte. Ich hatte schon interessante Diskussionen, dass man müsste doch da raufgehen. Das ist wirklich nicht gestattet. Deswegen hoffe ich, dass es niemals als Anlass nahm, auf diesen Turm draufzusteigen.
Nein, niemand würde das tun. Das finde ich gut.
Alle sind hier sehr verantwortungsbewusst.
Aber natürlich.
Ich dachte ja, ich hätte damit gerechnet, dass das Camp noch ein bisschen mehr selbstversorgermäßig ist tatsächlich. Nachdem das ja auch so in den Ankündigungen schon ein bisschen so durchklang. Ich habe jetzt zwar schon viele Leute mit Solar-Panels, die ihre Powerbanks aufladen gesehen. Und es gibt ja hier und da auch mal so richtige Panels aufgestellt. Aber tatsächlich so beim Rumgehen dachte ich, ich hätte mehr erwartet. Und ja, das ist ein Eindruck.
Jetzt mehr Solartechnik erwartet.
Mehr Eigenversorgung und weniger Material-Schlacht mit so Komfort.
Also mehr Solar, weniger Bredenord.
Ja, was auch immer. Letty hat ja hier in der letzten Sendung mit Wasserfiltern und so angefangen. Und dann haben wir auch ein bisschen Solar und was auch immer besprochen. Aber ja, irgendwie sehe ich halt auch viel von dieser Material-Schlacht und immer mehr und immer größer und noch einen Raclette mitbringen und Waffeleisen und hast du nicht gesehen? Und nach dieser Veranstaltung, wo ihr übers Camp gesprochen habt und diese 100-Sattel-Schlepper, die hier reinfahren und so weiter. Ihr seht ja auch die Stromgeneratoren überall. Also eigentlich fände ich es auf jeden Fall ziemlich geil, wenn man das wirklich noch mehr öko-regenerativ wie auch immer hinkriegen könnte.
Das stimmt, das sind alles Dieselgeneratoren. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Aber ich finde, das zählt ja auch so in dieses Zuhause-Fühlen komfortabel. Nein, nicht komfortabel, aber so dieses Wohlfühlen halt einfach. Du willst halt nicht auf einer Veranstaltung sein, wo es kein gutes Essen gibt. Dann merkt man das sofort, dass alle Leute so ein bisschen so meh, scheiß Essen.
Hast du dir nicht dreimal Pilze aus dem Wald geholt und die haben dann bei uns gegessen?
Der erste war wirklich aus Versehen. Ich bin halt angehalten und am Wegesrand gucke ich so vor, mir ist so, oh ein Birkenpilz, das ist aber schön.
Wann hieß es, dass ich drei Stunden... Ja, die hat vor drei Stunden einen Pilz gefunden. Frag mal, ob sie noch lebt.
Ich nehme nur Pilze mit, die ich kenne. Und gestern war ich mit einer Freundin hier noch irgendwie Pilze jagen und da haben wir auch nochmal eine gute Mahlzeit gefunden. Na ja, so durch den Wald. Pilze sind Rudeltiere.
Du meinst du hast den ersten gegessen und die zweiten sind schon weggelaufen?
Nein, das waren wirklich nur Birkenpilze. Aber es war nicht so eine kluge Idee, irgendwie mit den Flip-Flops und kurzen Hosen in diesen Wald reinzurennen. Ich hab irgendwie so einen Stachel im Oberschenkel am Ende gehabt. Ja, ich hab auch direkt so Tala so. Sieht das noch gut aus?
Wenn's schlimmer wird, zum Zert kommen.
Kurze Frage zwischendurch, hat jemand ein Taschentuch? Ich als Heuschnupfer und Staubfreund.
Wo wir schon gerade bei der Erteilung sind, was fehlt? Vielleicht hat hier noch jemand einen Tipp für mich? Ich suche mal eine Gelegenheit, wo man mal einen Schokoriegel erwerben kann.
Ich hätte hier so...
Also es gibt ja super geile Karamell-Brownies, aber ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab dir hier noch welche mitgebracht.
Müsli-Schoko?
Ja, nee, so rege ist viel zu gesund. Ich meine so richtig ordinäre, so was.
Du kriegst nach der Sendung noch einen.
Sehr gut, alles klar.
Ich weiß, dass heute irgendwann...
Und die Gelddrucker. Zum Er-Autonomie bitte nächstes Mal mehr Gelddrucker mitbringen.
Gelddrucker?
Naja, so diese Dinger, die man bedroht mit Plastik und dann drucken die Geld.
Das wäre tatsächlich praktisch.
Stimmt, das gibt es gar nicht so lange.
Gibt es irgendeine Bank, die sich finden würde, die hier einen Geldautomaten hinstellt?
Das ist Berlin Only, oder was?
Und ich hätte da noch eine Anmerkung zum Grauwasser-Thema. So ein paar Urinade wären nicht verkehrt. Dann würden die Leute, die sich einfach wirklich nicht hinsetzen, vielleicht irgendwo hinstellen, wo es okay ist, weil kein anderer sich da hinsetzt.
Ich fühle das nicht weiter aus.
Aber glaub mir, es wäre besser.
Ich finde ja, man könnte in solchen Hygiene betreffenden Verhaltensweisen dann auch nochmal auf selbige einwirken.
Könnte man, hilft aber vielleicht nicht. Ganz so gut wie die andere Lösung.
Was mir so ein bisschen fehlt, sind die Kompoletten von dem Fusion-Griddle. Die finde ich ja so großartig, die stinkten auch nicht. Wobei, hier gibt es zum Glück keine Dixie-Klos. Als Frau ist es immer so ein bisschen so ein...
Doch, hier gibt es Daten-Klos. Du weißt auch, was mit denen passiert ist.
Ja, sie wurden viermal schon benutzt, weil sich jemand...
Aber hinterher korrekt, wir werden mit Kabelbindern geschlossen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht ist. Aber ich mein, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber als Frau finde ich immer so, dass so eine Veranstaltung steht und fällt mit der Hygiene.
Anstrengend. Für die Oberschenkel vor allem.
Entschuldigung, das verstehen nur die wenigsten. Hallo Frauen. Das fand ich auch in der Fusion irgendwie so interessant an dem Gelände, dass sie sich diese Kompoletten gebaut haben und du hast so dieses...
Das ist jetzt aber keine Gesichtsbehaarung, oder? Ach nichts.
Das sind Kompost-Toiletten.
Genau, Kompost-Toiletten, die mit Säge spielen und ab und zu, glaube ich, auch mit einer Schicht Erde versehen werden, in der du halt dein Geschäft verrichtest. Und was interessant ist, wenn es warm ist, stinkt es nicht. Und ich fand das immer irgendwie total toll. Ich weiß nicht, wie nachhaltig das ist.
Ich wollte auch gerade fragen, wieso weißt du, wie warm es ist.
Wie warm es ist? Ja, wenn es draußen warm ist.
Ich kann dir sagen, warum es nicht stimmt, weil diese Kompoletten Urin und Scheiße trennen.
Ja, aber ich fand, ich würde mich gerne, da könnte es im Übrigen mal ein CRE drüber machen.
Genau, genau.
Tim macht ein CRE. Über die Kompoletten, ob das nachhaltig ist und wie das funktioniert. Ich fand das interessant, dieses Prinzip zu sehen. Kackst da schön in diese Tonne rein oder pinkelst da rein, das ist ja auch egal. Aber ich fand das interessant, weil es im Vergleich zu anderen Festivals, wo du diese Dixie-Hölle hast, also nicht als Datenklot, Clemens, fand ich das echt interessant. Kannst du das mal machen?
Und wer trennt das, Tim?
Wie läuft die Trennung ab?
Wie wird es getrennt, wer trennt das?
Die Schwerkraft? Ich hab gesehen, dass da auch ein Rohrsystem war. Ich vermute, dass sie damit...
Das rupft sozusagen raus, also die Flüssigkeit läuft dann raus. Da sind so Gitter, genau, und dadurch wird das halt getrennt. Und die ganze Urin wird dann halt gleich da, wo auch die anderen Pissoirs alle hin abgeleitet werden, wird das sozusagen gleich weggeschickt. Aber was stinkt, ist immer der Urin. Die Scheiße stinkt eigentlich gar nicht, was ganz lustig ist eigentlich auch. Man denkt ja, die Scheiße stinkt, aber die Scheiße stinkt nicht.
Aber da konntest du mal ein CAA drüber machen. Das fand ich etwas sehr schreckt, Egan. Drüber.
Damit hast du die komplette Nahrungskette einmal abgearbeitet.
Ich bin mittlerweile so in dem Alter angekommen, wo ich sogar fünf Tage camp als zu kurz ansehe. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber es ist schon alles in so einem Equilibrium angekommen.
Das sind schon fünf Tage.
Du volontierst für den Abbau, höre ich gerade.
Ja, ich weiß, dass das alles Herausforderungen sind, gerade was so Helfer und auch bestimmte Kosten betrifft, die sich auch mit jedem Veranstaltungstag verlängern. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist irgendwie so dieses Mittwoch Anfang irgendwie auch nichts.
Du warst da schon vorher hier.
Das sind ja auch sehr viele.
Ja, ich wäre auch sonst vorher da. Dann wäre ich halt zwei Wochen hier. Das ist auch sehr schön. Oder drei?
Genau, die letzten drei Tage sind Talks.
Das ist doch okay. Ich finde schon, es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob du den Operations-Modus auch wirklich angeworfen hast oder ob du nur sozusagen darauf hinfieberst. Dieses Ein-Par-Tage-Vorher-Kommen finde ich einfach wichtig, um überhaupt erst mal ein bisschen runterzukommen und sich ein bisschen darauf einzustellen auf den ganzen Modus. Aber ich denke, es müsste eigentlich immer so weitergehen.
Die Dusche habe ich auch nicht an Tag 0 oder 1 gefunden. Es dauert, bis man hier alles mal gesehen hat.
Die Zertschichten helfen.
Genau, da wüsste ich noch ganz gerne, wer dieser Troll war, der das Zelt Johnson auf die eine Seite und das Hackcenter auf die andere Seite gepackt hat. Aber dann stand es im Plan genau andersrum. Wer war das? Zahlreiche Verabredungen sind gescheitert, weil ich den Leuten immer gesagt habe, sie sollen sich zum Zelt Johnson bewegen und Johnson war dann überhaupt gar nicht da.
Bitte melde dich.
Hat Johnson auch eine Decktnummer auf dem Rücken geklebt?
Aber das ist irgendwie der einzige Fehler, den ich so richtig erkennen kann an dieser Veranstaltung. Deine Karte ist einfach nicht up to date. Was?
Deine Karte ist einfach nicht up to date.
Das ist die Karte, die wir alle in die Hand bekommen haben.
Echt? Print oder was?
Ja.
Ach so.
Ich dachte, Print ist tot.
Ja, merkbar.
Deswegen.
Alles falsch. So, haben wir noch Themen?
Wir könnten ja noch mal auf diese Cardio zurückkommen.
Ich hab noch ein Request kurz. Ich bin hier nebenan, muss noch so ein Display reparieren und ich brauch einen... Artmeld Dragon, wenn's geht, wenn einer so was hat, kann er sich an mich wenden.
Was mit Cardio?
Ich finde, dass dieses Mal das Cardio einfacher zu bedienen ist, als vorher die Radio-Batch und vor allem auch das Zusammenfrickeln wesentlich einfacher geht, außer man verliert die Schrauben. Aber es ist wirklich nur einmal draufkleben, paar Schrauben zusammen, fertig, du hast deine Batch. Ich finde es sehr schön, keine Ahnung, wie gut diese Sensoren für das Cardio funktionieren, aber es blinkt erst mal ganz schön am Arm. Man sollte damit nicht auf Toilette gehen oder Händewaschen ist vielleicht auch schwierig, ein bisschen hochziehen. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das mit dem Wasser sich verträgt, aber... Aber mit schon duschen, auch schön, ja. Vielleicht kann man damit auch duschen.
Ja, und lebt die Cardio noch? Nein, ja super. Merkst du selber, oder?
Einmal.
Genau, ein einziges Mal.
Ich hab übrigens heute erst entdeckt, oder gestern Abend, oder durch Zufall, durch einen Tweet der Firma Bosch, wir sagen jetzt nur den Namen, um das Vok zu dissen, dass da ein Luftgütesensor mit drauf ist.
Luftgüte?
Ja, da hab ich noch keine Abführ gefunden.
Ja, doch, man kann so Temperatur sehen, Hektopascal und irgendeine Einheit-Lukumkante.
Nee, das Ding soll Gas schnüffeln können. Es soll gefährliche Gase schnüffeln können.
Vielleicht war das das.
Und das erzählt dir die Firma Bosch.
Hör auf meinen Staub.
Es sind immer noch 27°C.
Aber da gibt es noch keine Abgase.
Irgendjemand anderes meint, das ist die zweite Zeit.
Ihr müsst das wiederholen. Dieselabgase lassen sich damit nicht schnüffeln, habe ich verstanden. Stimmt das?
Das ist ja auch von Bosch oder nicht?
Wer, der da?
Bei der Sensor wahrscheinlich, oder?
Meine ist gerade die Batterie verstorben hier in der Sendung. Hat jemand den USB-Lader da?
Denne sicher hat sein Kabel nur so zu impfen.
Aber ich hab's ja hier.
Jetzt wird erstmal die Makita Powerbank an die Uhr angeschlossen.
Die Idee finde ich ganz interessant, über Micro-Python an das Gerät heranzugehen. Beim IMF-Camp auf dieser Tilder-Batch gab es das ja auch schon. Das ist auf jeden Fall erstmal eine Hürde weniger, als mit C herumzuarbeiten. Wenn man das nicht kennt und Python ist, finde ich schon nochmal eine gängigere Sprache oder eine einfache Sprache.
Python ist die Hürde.
Wollen wir noch über Tabs und Spaces reden? Da wären wir nie fertig. Ich fand das irgendwie schön und ich hab jetzt auch nichts Besonderes gemacht, außer mal so irgendwie den... so einen Regenbogen über das HSV. Das hattest du mir ja mal empfohlen, nicht über RGB einen Regenbogen lupen zu lassen, sondern über diese HSV-Farbskala. Und irgendwie läuft da jetzt halt fast ein Regenbogen über meine Uhr. Mit einem Offset natürlich, damit nicht jede dieselbe Farbe hat. Das ist sehr schön.
Nicht über St. Pauli? Ein Fußballwitz muss sein, oder?
Hey, dass Tim noch nichts über Fußball geredet hat. Ehe so, warst du nicht am Sonntag bei Union?
Soll ich jetzt da was zu erzählen?
Nee, das wollen wir nicht.
Das war auch nicht so glorios, oder?
Sprich das doch nicht an, doch, das war extrem glorios.
Ich hab's dir nicht gesagt, guck Roddy an.
Diese LSD-Farbmodi sind auch echt...
Kommen wir zu den Anwendungen. Ich kritisiere ja immer die Anwendung. Und ich find das ja ganz toll, dass wir so Hardware-Plattformen haben, die dann alles Mögliche theoretisch ermöglichen können. Man könnte ja, ein Sensor hier und ein Sensor da. Aber frage mich halt immer noch, ob nicht für ein Device nicht primär auf das Event hin ausgerichtet sein sollte.
Da sind Raketen drauf. Ja, in blau, in gelb und grün.
Jedes Mal, wenn du an Dingen vorbeiläufst, kannst du dir dann ein EKG machen oder deine Herzfrequenz anschauen und sagen so das berührt mich so sehr gerade, dieses Licht da im Baum.
Kannst du das dann auch per Bluetooth an dein Telefon schicken und das dann per Instagram mit deinen Freunden sharen?
Die Leute, die gestern dieses Schüttelspiel gespielt haben, fand ich aber auch sehr lustig anzuschauen.
Du willst dir das vom Thema ablenken oder was?
Nee, da gibt es so ein Spiel, wo er misst, wie stark du die Hand bewegst. Wenn du sie zu stark bewegst, dann geht dein Licht von grün auf rot und dann bist du draußen. Und der letzte, der noch irgendwie eine grüne Uhr hat, der gewinnt dann. Und dann rennen die da wie die Bekloppten rum.
Ja, ist das korrekt? Ja, das ist auch nicht neu, das gab es schon, ich weiß nicht, das gab es schon vor länger, ich weiß nicht, schon eine ganze Weile unterwegs. Ja, das ist an sich ein ganz gutes Beispiel, wie ich finde, weil es nämlich tatsächlich für die Dynamik auf der Veranstaltung enorm was beiträgt. Also wenn du so acht Leuten zuschaust, die dieses Spiel spielen, also für die Leute, die es noch nicht verstanden haben oder nicht gesehen haben, das ist so ein bisschen, als wenn du so ein Waffeleis in der Hand hast, quasi aber als Gerät, wo dann die Eiskugel leuchtet, also im Prinzip ein bisschen digitaler Eierlauf. Und die Kugel signalisiert halt mit ihrer Farbe ihren Zustand und wenn sie halt noch nicht genug geschüttelt ist, dann hat sie irgendeine Farbe und wenn man es halt so schnell macht, dann wird sie rot und dann ist man raus. Und da halt acht oder zehn Leute gleichzeitig irgendwie so einen Teil in die Hand gedrückt bekommen, wabern sie jetzt alle wirklich so wie so Eurythmisten aus der Waldorfschule umeinander herum und versuchen die anderen in so eine Situation zu bringen, in der sie sich zu viel bewegen, ohne dabei natürlich sich selbst zu viel zu bewegen. Und das erzeugt tatsächlich interessante Muster. Ich hab mir das an diesem wunderschönen Bus, der hier irgendwo steht, habt ihr den gesehen? Dieser Bus, der oben noch mal so einen Balkon oben drauf hat, ist auch großartig. Also ein Bus, wo so quasi eine Holzdecke oben drauf ist. Ja, du kannst einfach in den Bus rein und dann stehst du irgendwie da oben, wirst auch mit Getränk begrüßt und so weiter und kannst dich da über Künstliche Intelligenz unterhalten. Und man kann vor allem halt von oben schauen. Da sah ich dann auch gerade mal wieder so eine Bande dieses Spielspiel. Und ich fand das einfach so von der ganzen Raume-Ästhetik erstmal ganz nett, weil du hast natürlich im Dunkeln diese leuchtenden Eier, die dann sozusagen die ganze Zeit umeinander kreisen. Aber es ist natürlich auch so von dieser ganzen physischen Interaktion, die Menschen so miteinander haben, auch ein schönes Bild. Wir wissen ja also, dass der gemeine Nerd gemeinhin ja sozusagen Bewegungsprobleme hat. Und auch was die soziale Interaktion betrifft, alles noch so ein bisschen verbessernfähig ist. Solche Sachen natürlich ganz gut. Wenn wir das dann wieder zurück übertragen auf die Idee eines Badge im Sinne von etwas, was jeder bekommt und jeder trägt, würde man sich da nicht wünschen, auch etwas als Anwendung auf so einem Gerät zu haben, was genau solche Effekte auch befeuert.
Es ist schon staubig genug auf dem Camp.
Außerdem kannst du dir sagen, ob du angesprochen werden möchtest oder nicht.
Exakt, ganz wichtiges Video.
Ja, grün und rot. Aber hast du gesehen, wie viele Leute mit blinkenden LEDs durch die Gegend rennen? Ich meine, da weißt du ja überhaupt nicht mehr, was das bedeutet. Du bist rot und grün gleichzeitig. Machst mich ganz muschig.
Wo ist deine Uhr? Hier. Nein, die andere. Die richtige.
Ja, ich hab das noch nicht. Ich meine, EKG hab ich schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Mir wurde vorhin gesagt, dass es möglich ist, per Bluetooth-LE den Buzzer einzuschalten. Das hat Toto rausgefunden. Da ist ja so ein kleiner Vibrationsmotor drinnen, und den kann man per Bluetooth-LE einschalten, auch ohne Authentifizierung. Und dann kann man für jeden, der im Umkreis ist und BLE eingeschaltet hat, kann man... Genau!
Ja, aber das ist in der Tat schon mal ein ganz guter Ansatz. Also ich meine, man könnte ja im Prinzip so einen Hidden Tinder einbauen.
Tinder als App gab es schon.
Auf dem Kardio? Und wie funktioniert die?
Untergeladen.
Ach so.
Rainbow Improved war drüber und das muss ich nehmen.
Naja, wenn dann sozusagen deine potenziellen Partner in Crime in deiner Nähe sind, dann fängt es halt so an zu vibrieren. Und dann musst du um dich herum schauen, wer von denen so aussieht, als würdest du auch gerade vibrieren.
Das läuft im normalen Leben genauso.
Ja, genau, das ist quasi so ein Emotionsverstärker. Vielleicht kann man ja auch mit diesem Herz... Was ist das noch? Also, aber man muss ja da sozusagen nochmal ein spezielles Kabel ranmachen und sich dann wirklich diese Kontakte irgendwo drauf machen.
Nee, du hast keinen Sensor, machst einfach deinen Daumen drauf.
Die Kabel sind extra.
Ach, die Kabel sind extra?
Musst du nicht benutzen.
Ein Kanal, EKG, also.
Okay, na super, und können wir da auch so Emotionen, also so Anwallungen?
Pulsrate kriegst du auf jeden Fall hin. Und Aussetzer vom Herzschlag.
Dann ist eh schon.
Dann sind da die, die nicht zusammen passen vielleicht.
Ja, vielleicht.
Das ergibt das natürlich auch.
Die Linie ist recht flach.
Also wär dein sozusagen Puls-Sensor nicht viel sinnvoller?
Ist es ja quasi.
Weil wenn du EKG-Ausschläge hast, dann siehst du gleichzeitig auch deinen Puls.
Dein Herz schlägt verkehrt rum.
Ich glaube, ich hab Herzprobleme.
Wollen wir zum Zert gehen? Wir haben coolen EKG, auch mit mehr als eine Kanal-Ableitung. Sogar zum Ausdrucken.
Was möchtet ihr den Menschen hier noch mit auf den Weg geben heute?
Alles Liebe.
Geht auf fehlkauf.bilt, liked, retweeted, shared.
Was ich jetzt meine, wir haben jetzt noch einen Tag Zeit. Dinge, die ihr hier gesehen habt, von denen ihr möchtet, dass man sie unbedingt gesehen hat.
Auf dem Berg hab ich beim Aufbau gesehen. Danach hab ich es aber nicht mehr hingeschafft. Jungs, die eine steuerbare Antenne haben, die die Wetter-Satelliten verfolgen und deren Daten abgreifen. Und?
Werden die Daten nicht sowieso bereitgestellt?
Genau, selber machen.
Ah, den Downlink.
Außer im drehen Antennen sind doch cool. Nicht?
Du bist so ein einfaches Gebiet.
Ja, mehr Sachen mit Holz und kleinen Antennen.
Ich finde, man soll sich hier verlieren. Einfach mal wirklich rumlaufen und mal wissen, wo man nicht mehr ist, wenn man so geflasht ist von den Eindrücken, die hier so sind, von den Lichtern. Ich hab ein paar Sachen entdeckt, die auf dem Kongress, glaube ich, auch standen. Irgendwo ganz woanders, weil ich von oben drauf geschaut hab. Nur dann hab ich es überhaupt erst gesehen, diese Strukturpalme. Die stand bei Saal 2 irgendwie in dem Raum, ich weiß immer nicht, wie die ganzen Sachen heißen, in irgendeiner Halle. Die hab ich irgendwie so von oben herauf, schön beleuchtet gesehen.
Bitte?
Chaos West, genau, stimmt.
Eine Strukturpalme?
Ja, so eine Palme.
Steht neben der Rakete.
Ein Stück weiter davor, ja.
Egal, je nachdem aus welcher Richtung du guckst.
Wenn man von oben guckt, steht sie davor.
Was ist denn eine Strukturpalme? Du hast es gesagt, also ich frage ja noch.
Eine Palme aus Struktur.
Struktur, genau. Nicht aus Blättern.
Nicht aus Blättern.
Keine Blätterpalme, sondern eine Strukturpalme. Ich finde das so offensichtlich.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht, was Sache ist.
Wenn du sie siehst, wirst du dich daran erinnern und dann siehst du, das ist eine Strukturpalme.
Einfach nach einer Palme-Ausschau halten, Tim, und dann ist alles gut. Oder nach so einer Tiki-Body aufhören.
Und wenn die ordentlich Struktur hat, dann ist es eine Struktur-Palme.
Die Tiki-Bar ist ja hier so ein Import aus Seattle.
Kennen die alle nicht.
Wer kennt was nicht?
Die Tiki-Bar. Von früher meinst du diese Video-Serie?
Nein, ich meine nicht diese Video-Serie.
Die Video-Serie, die du machst, an die ich natürlich auch zuerst denken musste, als ich das gehört habe, ist ja sozusagen nur spielt in einer Tiki-Bar. Aber Tiki-Bar ist an sich ja ein Konzept. Und Tiki-Bar ist halt im Wesentlichen Hawaiianische Cocktails in den passenden Dings anbieten. Und die haben sich den Spaß gemacht, halt nicht nur eine Tiki-Bar hier mit irgendwie aufs Camp zu schleppen, sondern sich jeden Tag woanders hinzustellen. Das ist ganz lustig. Mobile Tiki-Bar. Ja genau, also ich kann euch nicht sagen, wo ihr hingehen müsst, aber es gibt irgendwo eine Tiki-Bar, die man finden kann und dann gibts da Drinks.
Und Hawaii-Shirts. Die haben auch eine Garderobe.
Und Hawaii-Shirts. Und man darf die auch mitnehmen.
Muss man das Shirt anziehen, um einen Drink zu kriegen?
Man kann das tun, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht Pflicht.
Wir sind doch auf dem Camp. Aber die besten Sachen findet man auf jeden Fall sowieso, wenn man nach ganz anderen Sachen sucht. Also das zu diesem Mal gehen, laufen lassen und so. Ich hab auf jeden Fall auch mir immer jeden Tag eine Mission gestellt, was ich finden müsste. Und hab dabei ganz viele andere tolle Sachen gefunden. Zum Beispiel die Eiswürfelmaschine hab ich gleich an Tag Null gefunden. Das haben ganz viele andere gesucht, verzweifelt und ich hab die schon gefunden.
Wir sind einfach hingegangen.
Aber es gibt Leute, die haben sie bis heute noch nicht gesehen.
Aber dabei zeigen überall Schilder in Richtung.
Ja, aber mit diesen ganzen Wegen und bei Nacht. Also ich hab gestern mich auch nochmal verlaufen, tatsächlich auf dem Camp.
Die steht hier in unserer Wegkreuzung, ne?
Genau, auf der.
Direkt neben einem Dreh den Ort, man kann's gar nicht verfehlen.
Der kleine Huckel möchte vom Zert abgeholt werden.
Hast du die Decke hinten drauf?
Ich hab's nicht geschafft, auf so einer Bahn mitzufahren. Das hätt ich gerne gemacht.
Die fahren auch selten, da hab ich den Eindruck.
Eine Bahn oder eine selbstgebaute Bahn?
Irgendeine Bahn, egal was.
Da ist ein Fahrplan, da steht.
Ich bin einfach bei einer zugestiegen, die vorbeikam.
Manchmal fahren sie und manchmal nicht.
Ja, die haben nicht... Also dann hätte sie mich überfahren fürchtig.
Also nicht von den fahrenden Bahnen runterspringen. Vor allem, wenn man normalerweise sitzender Informatiker ist.
Im Haus beruflich.
Verdrehte Knie und verstauchte Knöchel sind Hochkonjunktur.
Die Bewegungsexpertin hat gesprochen.
Ist generell so ein bisschen unpraktisch von schneller fahrenden Objekten.
Reden wir von der gleichen Bahn? Schneller fahrende Objekte?
Die sind teilweise ganz schön. Man unterschätzt es auch, wenn man drauf steht und denkt, die ist langsam genug, dass ich springen kann, aber eigentlich nicht in der Lage bin zu springen und schon gar nicht sinnvoll zu landen.
Apropos Haltestellen, die aufploppen beim Pilze sammeln. Nein, wir waren nüchtern. Wir sind irgendwo reingekommen und da gab es so eine Gartensiedlung und auf einmal stand da so eine Abfahrtsplan von einer BVG, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas Mildenberg nach, keine Ahnung, wirklich so im Nichts vor so einem einzelnen Häuschen, so ein alter, ich glaube, es ist ein alter BVG-Fahrplan. Wir standen da so, okay, mit Busabfahrtzeiten. Also hier wird man nicht nur auf dem Camp getrollt, sondern auch ein bisschen außerhalb.
Ich hab ja hier meinen Landsitz in der Nähe und ich kann dir sagen, dass bis vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit fuhr der Bus bei uns Donnerstags.
Das Ding ist, wenn man den verpasst, braucht man ein bisschen. Da gab es keine richtige Straße, also jedenfalls keine befestigtes Gartenwaldweg.
Ist das vielleicht so für Seniorenheime, wo die Leute, es gibt es wohl wirklich, dass in Seniorenheime für demente Leute Haltestellen aufgebaut werden, damit sie...
Nicht mehr wissen, dass sie gar nicht mehr in Berlin sind.
Nee, da gehen die da hin und warten auf den Bus, wenn sie wegrennen wollen.
Demente Leute müssen meistens immer gerne öffnen, wenn sie irgendwo hin sind. Das ist so ein Krankheitsbild, dass sie das Gefühl haben, irgendwo hin zu müssen. Aber sie sind da nicht so crazy, dass sie dann losjoggen, sondern sie setzen sich halt hin und warten auf den Bus. Und abends werden die da wieder einkassiert. Und da kommen halt nur die Pflegergelenklich mal vorbei.
Mit dem Bus hoffe ich dann.
Ich hab das in einem Altenheim auch wirklich mal gesehen. Das war an die Wand gemalt, eine Bushaltestelle, aber da war niemand da.
Ich hab ja eine Geschichte gehört, dass Leute im Floß oder am Boot anreisen wollten, aber dann die Schleuse einen Defekt hatte. Das Floß oder das Boot zurückbleiben musste und dann ein Nerd mit 37 Kilometer mit Rucksack irgendwie zum Camp alleine dann aufgebrochen ist und die anderen zurück an der Schleuse gelassen hat.
Nach dem Fußmarsch ist da doch kein Nerd mehr.
Fand ich auch ganz putzig.
Ich find's sehr lustig am Kidspace. Ich neige auch dazu, wenn ich ins Wasser gehe, mich sehr, sehr dumm anzustellen und mich nicht reinzutrauen. Die einfachste Technik ist ja, einfach reinzuspringen. Aber hier ist das regelrecht so ein Fließband an...
An Nisstrauern.
An sehr, sehr blassen Männern, die sich nicht ins Wasser reintrauen und dann alle so Zentimeter für Zentimeter gehen.
Ich habe Farbe bekommen.
Aber wirklich auf der Hand.
Wann machst du das letzte Mal duschen? Es gibt ganz oft diesen Effekt. Ich habe Farbe. Nein, das ist Dreck. Du musst mal wieder duschen.
Das ist tatsächlich was, was ich auch... Also jetzt nicht unbedingt sehenswert, eher nicht sehenswert. Trinkt genug und wascht euch regelmäßig Hände und Füße.
Ich meine, du läufst zur Dusche, hast die saubersten Füße dort, musst 20 Minuten zurücklaufen. Die sind schmutziger als zuvor. Also es ist unmöglich hier staub...
Ja, da gibt's...
An sich ja.
Ich kann aber sagen, diese Füße wurden nicht geduscht. Wurden nicht sauber gemacht.
Da gibt's ein Life Hack, fahr mit dem Fahrrad. Dann musst du nicht in dem Dreck rumrennen. Fahrrad.
Immerstiefel.
So ein Fahrrad.
So ein Fahrrad ist super.
Ja, hab ich doch gleich am Anfang erzählt.
Ja, aber noch hier.
Von Tim Habe.
Echt?
Dir schreibt ein Hafen?
Mir hat der Hafen geschrieben, ja.
Aber was ganz Persönliches und Privates.
So, wenn es auch eine schöne ginge. Wer da noch nicht war, ist ein bisschen oft noch mal von hier, aber da hinten gibt es noch so einen Hafen.
Das ist auch meine Mittagsstelle.
Ich finde ja diese Chaos Post wirklich ein ganz hervorragendes Ding, weil man wirklich auch zu... Diese Möglichkeit, irgendwie Leute zu erreichen, von denen man noch nicht mal weiß, wer sie sind. Das ist toll.
Kennt ihr eigentlich das TOC, das Turtle Operations Center? Unsere Schildkröte vom Zert hat tatsächlich Post bekommen und sie hängt ganz...
Wieso hat denn das Zert eine Schildkröte?
Zur Beruhigung. Hinter dem Zelt haben wir sogar mit Livestream inzwischen... Zert Twitter, da ist der Link drauf. Und man kann der Schildkröte zugucken.
Das ist das Turtle Operations Center.
Ja, das ist das TOC.
C3 TOC. Ich hoffe, es kommen keine Westmanns.
Nein, C3 TOC ist Troll Operations. Rupert heißt er.
Rupert hat Post bekommen. Und das ist tatsächlich auch das Naste, wie ich an die Post Engel rangekommen bin.
Oh, da beugt sich gerade jemand über Rupert.
Ich hoffe, er landet nicht in der Suppe.
Also wenn wir hier mal den zweiten Screen nochmal aufmachen können, dann können wir uns mal Rupert kurz anschauen.
Das endet in einem Desaster.
Da brauchen wir ja keinen Ton.
Rupert liegs.
So, und das soll jetzt live sein?
Bist du aber sicher, dass dieser Mensch im Bild da auch zu gestimmt hat?
Klaut der die gerade oder was macht der mit dir?
Aber es strömt hier auch nicht wirklich. Wahrscheinlich geht das wieder alles nur...
Buffering.
22.36, zwei Minuten alt.
Ja, was soll ich machen? Ich kann es nochmal laden.
Einfach laufen lassen.
Geht wahrscheinlich nicht mit Apple.
Gibt es schon Livecrime.feel-Kaufwörter?
Steigen sie jetzt ein.
Nur hier die echten Turtles.
Das scheint mir echt ein gutes Businessmodell zu sein.
So, habt ihr noch Wünsche? Und sonst irgendwelche Sachen, die nicht in Hinweis sind? Hier liegen noch Sticker. Wir haben noch Sticker zu verschenken.
In Farbe und Bund. Und eckig und rund.
Ja.
Soße und Schaf, wir wissen das. Sonst nichts?
Nö, gut.
Dann schocken wir uns. Wir leiten mal das unvermeidliche Ende ein.
Das war früher aber länger.
Was?
Aber damals gab es auch noch Getränke.
Tim möchte heute nicht mehr über Max reden.
Früher gab es was? Getränke? Davon weiß ich nichts. Und Eis.
Dann sehen wir uns auf dem Kongress, oder?
Genau, dann sehen wir uns auf dem Kongress. Ihr hört uns irgendwann in den nächsten Wochen wieder, wenn wir wieder Freak Show machen. Das war die etwas trollige kleine Ausgabe hier. Ist das nicht toll?
Alle.
Danke.